hurry up and get vaccinated for uncle
joe's
fourth of july party it's my favorite
holiday
and boy do i love those fireworks we're
gonna have sparklers
shooters hoppers spinners i'll be on the
grill firing up hot dogs
one per person please we're getting
regular lays
and big lays and jill's picking up the
good costco cookies
you know the ones sprayers bubblers
whoop-dee-doos whirly gigs doozy-doo's
kamikazes loop-de-loops
that beautiful flag cake i mean come on
heck
that's just gorgeous i'm driving into
pennsylvania to get the good fireworks
they're legal there mini booms and mega
booms
i'll get the steely dance station going
on pandora
it's easy i just say alexa play
steely dan playing steely dance no not
now dagnammit
the star one the happy face the one
that's a ring within a ring there's only
one thing i like more than trains
and that's fireworks except maybe a
train full of fireworks
oh wouldn't that be something christ you
don't want to miss this party
tell your tic tac friends get vaxxed for
the booms
biden out